in the Batmobile don't hold the road
like this [ __ ] tight pants and fast
cars don't make you Fatman Mike
[Applause]
get me the [ __ ] out of this car
we got more time behind us than in front
half please I'm gonna be running down
criminals till I'm 100 not me on guitar
this time we be pudding men
who the [ __ ] wants to sing that song
Mike I'll put you on a new team you're
working with mo now okay mo is a high
school musical boy band wit gun you look
great grandpa so you're that guy there's
always one right up til there's not
that's what I like teamwork
Marcus somebody's trying to kill me who
wants to kill you I don't trust a person
that don't wanna kill he'll put my name
thanks a lot we got it Marcus we
appreciate it
but family is the only thing that
matters so I'm not letting you go on a
suicide mission alone one last time one
last time
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
when the hell are you getting all these
helicopters
oh this is my wife's car cover the front
door she knows he always knows
you